[Music]
[Music]
happy 2022 you just tapped into the
group chat live in the bleacher report
app presented by fanduel i'm greg ivory
alongside the lovely live moods live it
is a new
year i know a lot of us have betting
resolutions
so get in the comments everybody get in
the comments and tell me your new year's
betting resolutions liv do you have any
i do new year
new live my priority this year is
staying healthy and cashing out so as
long as i'm healthy and i'm cashing out
of my beds i will be happy in 2022.
liv i am not mad at you for that i'm not
mad at you for that uh also some big
news are new york bettors shout out to
new york
uh i heard
betting has been legalized in new york
and fanduel will be live in new york
this saturday january the 8th so get on
fanduel and register to place your bets
starting this weekend as always as
always we are giving away hoodies we're
giving away locks and we're giving away
jerseys so get in the comments i need
gifts i need emojis but most importantly
i need winners only please matter of
fact i want to give out a jersey right
now liv i'm in the comments i want to
give out a jersey right now to a lucky
uh a lucky commenter and i see
i see uh here we go
i see tom brady underscore hater
oh
great username but my my guy name is
nathan his name is nathan he says jalen
is gonna go for 23 tatum is going to go
for 32. i like that and i'm going to
tell you why i like that later in the
show but uh shout out to you you are
walking away
with a hoodie um
let's get right to it liv it's tnt
basketball thursday
tnt basketball thursday and fanduel is
boosting the 3x2 in both games tonight
the question is will there be two
three-pointers in the first three
minutes of the game
today we asked you on twitter which
three by two will cash tonight is it the
boston celtics taken on the new york
knick or is it the los angeles clippers
taking on the phoenix
suns here are the results
there they are you see the clippers the
clippers and the suns are in the league
here i need you guys to get in the
comments and tell us which three by two
is a lock lift talk to us which one do
you like best
yeah i mean
my problem is it is a tight race for a
reason because i was kind of on both
sides of this one going back and forth
however both the clippers and the suns
rank top five for their opponents having
the lowest three point percentage so
both the clippers and the suns guard the
three very well which made me
automatically want to avoid that one the
knicks ranked top 10 in three pointers
attempted and made and the celtics
ranked top 12 for three pointers
attempted and top 15 for three pointers
made so i actually think the safer bet
here is this celtics knicks match up so
that's what i'm gonna ride with but it's
a tight race so i could see maybe a
little sprinkle on both like you always
like to do
you know i like to sprinkle it on both
like to sprinkle it around that one's
interesting liv liv that one's
interesting because uh that one that
under is kind of low over understanding
that i believe 209 around there uh so
it's interesting uh but let me get into
the comments i gotta see what the people
are talking about and i am giving away
hoodies liv uh
i see britney britney is in agreement
with you liv she says seas and nyx
always go with the underdog shout out to
you brittany you are walking away with
the hoodie uh
snoopy snoopy is in the comments snoopy
2153 says campbell always goes off
versus boston he's probably giving us a
a pointer on what we should be taking in
uh a segment that's coming up soon uh
but i guess he's staying take the knicks
money line or nick's spread so uh shout
out to you snoopy you are also walking
away that's that's enough that that's
enough i think i'm just gonna make a
decision here
i i'm going to make a decision here the
squad ride the 3x2 that we are riding
with we're we're just going to go with
you we're going to rock with the boston
celtics taking on the new york knicks uh
i'm making the decision i'm putting my
foot down and we're believing that you
live so let's all ride
let's all ride together uh jason tatum
and jaylen brown have been averaging liv
49.9 points combined per game
today we asked you in the app what will
their combined point totals be tonight
get in the comments and tell us what you
think at the end of the game will dm one
random person who guessed correctly and
hook you up with a jersey let's take a
look at the current player points odds
here
liv what do you like here do you think
tatum and brown will cover their overs
i do think that they both have the
potential to cover their overs but i'm
actually looking at someone else tonight
i am looking at julius randle over 21
and a half points tonight i love the
odds and i also love this line for him
tonight the celtics give up the sixth
most points to opposing power forwards
he has averaged
and a half points in the two games
played against the celtics and he has
hit this over in three of the last five
with an unhealthy starting lineup for
this knicks team tonight i really like
julius randle to prioritize scoring
tonight and hit over 21 and a half
points
i like that liv i like that one a lot uh
let me hop into the comments let me see
what the people are talking about uh
i have brben's in the comments we are
betting shout out to be our betting uh
let me see uh
mike bolan is in the comments
uh
maxwell rexella maxwell rexell is
rocking with alex burke shout out to you
max russell you are walking away with a
hoodie mike raider is also in the
comments he is riding he's riding with
you liv he said he's taking julius
randle uh shout out to both of you guys
you two are walking away
with hoodies uh i'll hop in here liv
this one this one's tricky i'm gonna
rock with jason tatum i'm gonna rock
with jason tatum and i want you guys to
hear me out
he scored 19 in his last game against
sandy in a loss it was it was a loss
against san antonio and he struggled he
struggled he shot six for 20. jayson
tatum is coming off of of of an absence
because he was in health and safety
protocols and uh
i think that he's gonna bounce back
today he's gonna be more aggressive
because he knows in order for that
celtics team
to have a chance at winning today he
needs to score so i i like him to score
tonight do i think the celtics are going
to win not so fast i'm not saying that i
just like my guy jt to put up some
buckets tonight i want you guys to
remember after the game we're gonna hit
up one person and hook you guys up with
a jersey of your choice live it's my
favorite part of the show let's talk
major markets money lines and against
the spritz and point totals for
tonight's game let's take a look
at the odds live
are you seeing
i mean what are you seeing here and what
do you like
yeah i really like this clipper sun's
under under 220 and a half not only did
the under hit the last time that these
two teams met and i know some will argue
well there was no eight and there was no
booker well tonight there is no eight
and there is no crowder so this sun's
team is still not in full health and
neither is this clippers team um
55.3 percent of the clippers matchups
this season have gone up under and 51.4
of the sun's matchups have gone under so
i'm actually gonna take under 220 and a
half in this matchup
liv is rocking with the under okay liv
that is i like that i like that rocking
with the trans rocking with the under i
am in the comments gotta go to the
comments
because uh i gotta see what they are
talking about um
i got eli eli says he
yes i'm gonna do the under because the
clips ain't going over a hundred shout
out to you eli you are walking away with
the hoodie i also got officially
enderman i think he changed his name but
officially in her man tatum and brown
will combine for 63 points 28 points for
tatum 35 for brown shout out to both of
you two you guys are walking away with
hoodies live i'll jump in here i'll jump
in
i'm gonna rock
with the new york knicks at home i think
it's value in the knicks
at home i think it's value within the
knicks at the garden they won four of
their last six boston is 1-4 against the
spread in their last five
and i mean the knicks are home i'm
rocking with the home team here boston
they've been struggling to start both of
these teams play defense that's why the
over unders kanalo but both of these
teams play defense but boston struggles
to they struggles close to the basket
they struggle to defend close to the
basket julius randle's going to be down
there i think he's going to have a good
game so uh i'm rocking with the knicks
to win this one um
let's move on live we talked major
markets now let's talk player props
it's time for lock or not i'm gonna put
up a prop
and i need all of you in the comments to
tell me whether it is a lock or it's not
live let's get right to it let's get
right to it first up is julius randle we
i just i was just talking about him liv
i was just talking about julius randle
to post a double double against the
celtics currently at minus 125 talk to
us live and please talk to us nice do
you like this one
i'm only talking nice right now okay i
think it's a lock i do like this play
randall has hit a double double in four
of the last six with an unhealthy knicks
starting lineup like i mentioned earlier
i think randall will have to do a little
bit of everything but i think he will
prioritize shooting and rebounding he is
facing a celtics team that ranks bottom
10 and rebounds allowed not only that
but they also allow the third most
boards to opposing power forwards and as
i mentioned earlier the sixth most
points to opposing power forwards so
this is a big night for julius randle
especially if this knicks team wants to
get a dub here so julius randle for a
double-double is a lock
i agree with you liv i agree absolutely
uh
i'm rocking with that i'm rocking with
julius randle uh like i said the celtics
they struggle to defend the paint they
struggle to defend the paint so i see
him having a night tonight and we know
what he does on the boards we know what
he does on the boards he grabs them
consistently so i'm rocking with julius
randle to hit this double double i'm in
the comments though i'm in the comments
grabbing the handy danny because i want
to see what the people are saying uh
eli eli p dot says yup he is doing this
shout out to you eli you were walking
away with hoodie uh demario mcclain
demario mclean says it is a lock
that my guy julius randle goes for a
double double tonight so shout out to
both of you guys you two are walking
away with a hoodie next up live is serge
ibaka to record eight plus rebounds it's
sitting at plus 196.
do you like this one is this a lock or
is this not
this is tricky i i love a good rebound
play i really do and
it becomes tricky when
the mon the value i mean you look at
this value and you think it doesn't get
much better than that that is great
great great value um
any plus money is great value but
especially here i i do like it because
of the fact that we have some starters
out for both the clippers and the suns
and both centers are out for both the
clippers and the suns here so
this wouldn't be a play i'd go putting
my rent on or my student loan money on
but a little sprinkle when it's at plus
196 it's really hard to resist this one
with the starters being out especially
those being centers there's a lot of
opportunities for boards tonight so i
think it's a nice play i would sprinkle
i wouldn't go full on on this one but a
sprinkle i definitely think it's a lock
if you're sprinkling
liv you must got money to spend you must
got money
you know on on whatever because my guy
hasn't done this since december 20th
versus the spurs
that that's that's before christmas if
you guys don't know uh i'm cool i'm cool
i ain't got money to spend like that i'm
not putting my money on this uh i ain't
rocking with surge to go
uh to get eight plus rebounds i mean
yeah i'm cool off that lift i'm cool
let's move on to the next one let's move
on to the next one finally we got chris
paul to post 15 or more points against
his former team tonight uh sitting that
-114 live talk to me you like this one
yeah i i'm i'm gonna
initially say it's a lot but anything
with chris paul makes me nervous not
because i don't think he's capable but
because i don't know what his role is
going to be on any given night sometimes
we see him truly in that point guard
position as the facilitator and other
times we see him prioritize scoring with
some starters being out for this son's
team i worry that he may prioritize
scoring over uh being that facilitator
so if you're looking for his assist
because that's normally a lock for him
i worry that he's going to be focusing
on scoring so for the sake of this bet i
do think it's a lock the clippers are
also giving up an average of almost 24
points to opposing point guard so this
is a good spot for for paul tonight
there's no eight and there's no crowder
so booker bridges and paul are going to
have to split that offensive load
amongst the three of them to get the job
done tonight against this clippers team
because the last time that they faced
the clippers they did not get the job
done so i think 15 plus for chris paul
tonight is the play i worry about
assists for him just because i think he
will prioritize scoring more but 15 plus
i i say it's a lock
lift
you got some really good points there
you like
you're hitting it right on the nail uh
before before i give my take i'm gonna
get into the comments i want to see if
they're riding with you uh and that
might deter what i'm gonna say but
bad sports takes is spamming us in the
comments right now but he says that's a
lock he's going off with the fire emoji
shout out to you bad sports takes
usually i don't give them to spammers
but why not it's the new year so i'll
give it to you you're walking away
geek is in the comments d it is a new
year therefore you are walking away with
the hoodie live he said this is a lock
and i'm going to jump in
i'm going to jump in here and and this
one's sitting this one's sitting at -114
liv
i want you to to hear me out
chris paul hasn't he hasn't scored 15
plus points since christmas
so i would have thought that this would
be plus money i would have thought that
this would have been plus money if he
hasn't done it in weeks i would have
thought this would have been plus money
but it's sitting at -114 and i think
it's sitting at -114 for a reason
because the odds makers they know chris
paul is facing his former team tonight
and chris paul's gonna show up so
therefore i'm gonna rock with chris paul
to go over so i'm i'm locking this one
in i'm locking this one in liv i'm
rocking with you i'm rocking with the
audience uh
and it's time it is time to build the br
betting custom same game parlay which
you can ride
with us on fanduel but tonight we're
doing something special
in honor of betting being legalized in
new york we're doing two same game
parlays one for each tnt game tonight
while i give up
well i'll give out the parlays i need
everybody in the comments to tell me
what they think which legs are locks
which legs are not and let's start off
with our new york special live let's
start off with the new york special and
we talked about this guy we talked about
throughout the show you mentioned them
you talked about him he we actually did
us uh
the prop segment on them julius randle
to score 20 plus points
i like it
uh i'm rocking with it i i mentioned i
mentioned the celtics defense uh around
the paint
they've been struggling so give me my
guy julius reynolds to go 20 plus
tonight alex burke alex burke to record
two plus assists tonight live the former
warrior i can see him getting it done
finding two of his teammates that's all
we need i also mentioned this one
previously nick's money line i like this
one they're at home plus money give me
the knicks at home uh
and rj barrett
this one kind of scares me liv rj
barrett
two plus three pointers made
lift talk to me what do you think about
the new york parlay
i like it i think julius randle to score
20 plus is a great leg like i said
earlier he's facing a team that
struggles to guard that power forward
position uh berks with two plus assists
i think this is a great play he's hit
this in four of the last five uh and the
last i checked we didn't get kemba
walker in this one i don't know if
things have changed but if we don't get
kemba walker i love the play even more
nick's money line listen the celtics are
healthy right now so the knicks have got
to play some good defense in order to
win this game but i think it's possible
and i hate fading the knicks when
they're playing at home and finally rj
barrett definitely this leg makes me the
most nervous uh but it's possible and i
think if nick's money line is gonna cash
they're gonna need rj barrett at the
three-point line draining threes at
least two so if the knicks want to win
this one rj barrett's gotta hit some
three balls so this this is a good
looking parlay to me
that's facts that's facts live now let's
talk
clippers taking on
oh actually actually actually before we
talk clippers and sons i want to show
you guys the ticket they already pulled
it up but i want to let y'all know that
y'all gonna be walking away with
423 dollars if y'all was to put a
hundred dollars on that last new york
parlay now
let's talk clippers versus sons
let's get right to it liv let's get
right to it devin booker to score 25
plus points he's d book i like this one
moving on chris paul to record 10 plus
assists
i think he's going to score and i also
think he's going to dish tonight i think
chris paul's gonna have a big game
tonight he's facing his former team i
like this one reggie jackson we know
what he does he is a bucket reggie
and whenever it's a clutch moment and
you need a bucket i i will depend on
reggie jackson so i i i need 15 reggie
and i think
reggie can deliver those 15 and cam
johnson i really like this one right
here liv cam johnson three plus three
pointers made
yeah i'm feeling good about this one liv
but talk to me before i get into the
comments
no no actually actually liv before i get
into the comments talk to me do you like
this one tell me your opinion on it
i really like this same game parlay
devin booker 25 plus with a starting
lineup that is not completely healthy
booker is definitely the one that i
trust the most to score tonight he's hit
this in three of the last five and the
clippers have not played booker this
season because he was out with his
hamstring injury so they don't know how
to guard booker and i think he's the
secret weapon for this sunstone tonight
chris chris paul with 10 plus assists is
the one that makes me the most nervous
just because of the point i made earlier
i think he focuses on scoring tonight
however like you said if you think this
is a big night for chris paul there may
be some value in sprinkling on maybe a
double double for him tonight if you
think he'll do a little bit of both so
that's something to consider i do like
him to score a little bit more tonight
so this one is maybe the one that makes
me just a tiny bit nervous reggie
jackson for 15 plus points he had 19 the
last time that he played the suns this
season and the sun's allowed the third
most points to opposing point guards so
i love this spot for reggie tonight and
finally johnson with three plus threes i
love this leg he's hit this over and for
the last five and he hit this in the
last meeting with the clippers with no
crowder tonight i like him to get some
valuable playing time so i love this leg
i think overall it's the slam dunk
parlay
likes to live before i get into the
comments
which is your favorite part
i think my favorite parlay has got to be
this clippers sons i think all the legs
make sense i think we're gonna get a
nice game that we've you know a match-up
between these two teams and the last
time that we saw these teams play it
didn't go as many people would probably
expected the clippers came out on top i
don't think we'll see that again tonight
so i'm liking the same game parley i
think all the legs make sense and it
should hit
lives rocking with the suns i'm rocking
with both of them so guys go sprinkle
both of them um i'm in the comments i'm
in the comments i want to see what the
people are talking about i got
officially cut officially cut says
uh officially cut says sons minus two
and a half bookers going for off for 30
so the plus 25 is a no-brainer but take
the under 15 on paul assist
okay officially cut appreciate that
shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie
i'm also giving away jersey here live so
i'm looking for a good take i got julio
hernandez
liv and greg both of these parlays are a
plus randall going off against the
celtics uh defense tonight burks can
easily get two assists barrett will hit
uh two threes uh i love these shout out
to you julio hernandez you're walking
over honey uh liv it is time it's time
to give away
a jersey so i'm in the comments i am in
the comments and um
trigger way
trigger way he he gave us an um a gift
um and it says not today and if you guys
tune in to winners only wednesdays
that's one of the slogans so shout out
to you triggaway appreciate that you who
are walking away with the jersey of your
choice uh we talked mvps
a few times on the show and now you know
i st you guys know i i still love steph
curry to win the mvp uh but katie is now
just behind steph and giannis have been
surging as well i need you guys to get
in the comments and tell me who's your
lock to win mvp let's take a look at the
odds liv what's the best value on the
board do you think derozan is a good
long shot bet at plus 4 000
i have another long shot bet in mind
give me john marant at plus 5500
i gotta be honest with you i am a john
marant fan girl right now and i am not
afraid to admit it this dude is playing
next level basketball and i also think
this grizzlies team is extremely
underestimated and i think they are
going to go much further than people
anticipate we know that with this mvp
conversation a lot of people uh say that
it's a popularity contest and you've
kind of got to be on a winning team i
think the grizzlies are going to win
more than people anticipate i think john
moran is playing out of his mind i
actually grabbed him before the season
started at plus 3200 um or maybe a
couple weeks into the season then he got
injured now it's at plus 5500 i'm
sprinkling on it all over again i love
it and i think it's worth a sprinkle
liv i like that i like i i i like that
um if i had a long shot if i was betting
the long shot i will be riding with you
jaw has been
balling this year uh
and
with this mvp it takes a run jock can go
on the run he he can take that team on a
run and you know if he if he has a push
for two to three months and he takes his
team from you know a lower seat to a
higher seed i can see that actually
happening but there's somebody on the
top of that list by the name of stephen
curry uh that i think that i'm going to
rock with
but liv but i will say my guy kd katie's
a bad man kd is the best player
in the nba the most talented player in
the nba and he has been bald and he just
got his sidekick back and kyrie irving
um so
good play maybe maybe katie yeah he's a
good play but
i like my guy curry i like what he's
doing out there in golden state uh but
i'm in the comments because i want to
see who the people are
taking um
i got demario de mario mclean says kd
all the way shout out to you uh d geek
says i'm biased i'm i'm biased but i
don't understand d geek how am i biased
if steph curry is the favorite to win
the mvp how is that being biased he's
the favorite for a reason so i'm rocking
with craig is a warrior
i i am a warriors fanboy but but
i just don't understand how i was biased
if steph curry is the favorite to win
already like you know what i'm saying
like uh yeah anyway uh let me let me
give away some more hoodie let me give
away some more b royal one says between
katie and steph for sure shout out to
you you're walking away i got one more
hoodie in me
uh i absolutely agree with liv
jah is going to lead this team and
carried in them to a high see also he
has a chip on his shoulder to show uh
the fans to show the fans
what it is uh
my boy mike bowden is in the comments he
says demar derozan is getting played
shout out to everybody that i mentioned
you all are walking away with hoodies
all right liv it's time to take this
thing on home thank you guys for tapping
into the group chat presented by fanduel
remember what you learned today the
knicks celtics 3x2 is a lock also the
other game
it's a lock sprinkle them both get on
fanduel tell our br betting same game
parlays if you live in new york
get on fanduel and sign up uh be ready
to bet on saturday morning because
that's when betting becomes legal at 9
00 a.m eastern time we'll be back next
thursday giving out more hoodies more
locks and more jerseys and giving away
something special
very special because my warriors are
taking on the milwaukee bucks so if you
if you want if you guys want a hoodie
today if you guys want a hoodie today we
will dm you alongside liv moose i am
greg ivory we are leaving
the group chat peace
[Music]
you